What do you think about S-O-T or D-T where they take your blood cells and
tray them to attack your cancer? Yeah, we've had some patients go through S-O-T
therapy. There's a clinic down in Florida. There's one in Arizona, I think it
doesn't, and there's some in Mexico that do it. I don't know. I had one person
recently that started it, did several sessions and then stopped, didn't think it
was helping her, and I had somebody do it about two years ago. They thought it
helped them, but they were doing so many other things too. I don't know how they
could have discerned that. But, you know, I've heard good reports, so yeah, I've
not against doing these, so a lot of these alternative things. Also, I cut out
sweets and just about all sugar two years ago. Why is my hemoglobin A1C
state about 5.6 and 5.7 in the past has always been lower. There's other factors
with hemoglobin A1C, not just your sugar consumption, has to do with your
cell membranes and healing your cell membranes, and that takes a lot longer time.
It has to do with, you know, so your insulin receptors on your cell membranes don't
change easily. So, and then, you know, would you increase insulin receptors on
your cell membranes because of a bad diet for a long period of time? That's the
problem with diabetes. Type 2 is that you got somebody with type 2 diabetes, and
you think, oh, it's just an easy fix. You're just gonna go on a complete no sugar,
no carb diet, and that's gonna fix your problem, and people can't figure out why
it doesn't fix their diabetes. They still have elevated glucose levels. It's
because you're damaged to your cell membranes, and as that cell replicates a new
cell, it replicates a new cell with that same amount of insulin receptors on
it. So, that's really the issue. It's a cell membrane issue, and it just takes a
lot of time to move that needle.